well i hope you had a happy thanksgiving
with friends and family and too much
food and hopefully not too much politics
ever since we moved here nearly 10 years
ago i've loved the thanksgiving holiday
there's nothing like it in england i
love that it's not about gifts it's not
really commercialized not like christmas
and halloween and valentine's and all
the others anyway i love that this
holiday really is a chance to focus on
what truly matters your family your
friends the human things i did after all
write a book called more human
thanksgiving is the most human of all
the holidays
i love that the focus of thanksgiving is
coming together around the table for a
meal i love food yes okay i'm greedy i
love cooking i love the fact that
because there aren't all the other
distractions the thanksgiving meal
really is at the heart of this holiday
but this year thanksgiving was even more
special for me it was my first one as a
us citizen the first time i celebrated
this uniquely american holiday as an
american
now on a superficial level i was
thankful for the fact that i was able to
celebrate with my family in hawaii we've
spent thanksgiving week in the islands
every year since we moved here it's
become our tradition and there are a lot
worse places you could be
but this year i reflected on how
thankful i am not just to be in hawaii
but in america what an incredible
blessing and opportunity to have the
chance to actually become an american
part of the greatest nation in the world
in the history of the world and have the
chance to give something back by working
i hope to make it better
i'm so thankful to all of you for making
me feel so welcome you have no idea how
much i appreciate it i love seeing all
your comments after the show and i
especially love meeting you in person
when i'm out and about whether that's on
the beach or the flight home or in our
local neighborhood here in california
yes there are a lot of fox fans in
california and we need to stick together
we can all be thankful to be americans
there's nowhere in the world i'd rather
be that's for sure but even as we take a
moment to appreciate our great good
fortune to be americans
we need to recognize that america is not
just the physical place we inhabit with
all its beauty and majesty it's the idea
we were built on the idea of liberty
under the law the idea of
self-government expressed in so many
different aspects of the constitution
the most important and magnificent
political document ever written let's be
honest it's all under assault today
from an arrogant and elitist ruling
establishment from a rampant reckless
democratic party captured by the far
left
perhaps most perniciously from the
un-american authoritarianism of wokism
so when they try to take away our
freedom with spurious claims about
protecting public health and bogus
pseudo-scientific claptrap we must say
that is anti-american and we're not
going to stand for it
when they try to subvert the
constitution the idea of decentralized
power captured in the 10th amendment
with their insane build back better
legislation that aims to centralize
power in the federal government and its
bureaucracy we have to say that is
anti-american we won't let you do it
and when they try to extinguish the
beating heart of american
dynamism and exceptionalism the
foundational principle that no one can
tell you what to say or think that
everyone has the right to follow their
own path free from censorship or
coercion
we have a duty to tell the woke
authoritarianism your fascism is
anti-american it is not welcome here we
will fight you and defeat you just as we
defeated fascism before
so yes as americans we have a lot to be
thankful for
but with that comes a responsibility to
stand up for the very things that make
this country so great in the first place
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else